>>Ambarish Kenghe: Next, I'd like to bring
Brittany back on stage to show us a few Android
applications.
Brittany.
[ Applause ]
>>Brittany Bohnet: Thanks, Ambarish.
As many of you know, Listen, a product from
Google Labs, originally started as an audio
podcast application for your Android phone.
>>Brittany Bohnet: And today, we are excited
to announce that it's also coming to your
television.
The learning for all of you developers today
is not to name your applications too early.
Listen and Watch, as the name entails, now
includes content from video feed publishers.
And it includes the same functionalities as
it has on your phone.
You can search, subscribe, and access your
queue.
And today, you can also access a new feature,
called explore.
Explore is a directory where you can discover
new video podcasts.
So let's check one of these out.
"Tekzilla" is one of my favorites.
Let's try that one.
So we're going to access "Tekzilla."
Once we click into "Tekzilla," we can actually
see a list of results with all the different
podcast episodes that we can watch.
It's live HD video podcast right on your television.
So let me tell you about how this works.
So Android gives you a bunch of different
screen layouts for the different device types
you have.
And the Listen team has developed a single
binary that works on the TV and on the phone.
It's using Google's back-end feed infrastructure
so that you can continue to access all of
your subscriptions on all of your devices.
They all stay in sync.
So another interesting thing that the Google
TV developers do is syndicate search results
into our Quick Search Box.
If you can bring down the Quick Search Box.
Let me show you how it works.
And if we can't bring it down, then I'll tell
you how it works.
One of my other favorite podcasts is TEDTalks.
In the Quick Search Box, I can type in "TEDTalks,"
and you see I get the standard set of Google
TV search results.
There's also a link at the bottom that says,
"More results."
If I click on that link, I'm now able to search
within the Listen app itself.
Now I can get all of my episodes just from
a search.
It really is about spending less time finding
and more time watching the content that you
love most.
Okay.
One last application example I want to tell
you guys about.
This one was developed by a Google TV engineer
that works on our team.
He recently moved --
>>Ambarish Kenghe: Brittany, give me a minute
just to catch up.
Thank you.
>>Brittany Bohnet: He recently moved here
from one of our international offices.
And his wife moved with him.
She doesn't speak English, so she's been having
a really hard time watching U.S. television,
because she can't get the subtitles on her
TV here in the states.
So, the engineer started thinking.
And he decided to take the closed captioning
feed already available on his television and
the openly available Google Translate APIs,
and he created a new translate feature for
Google TV.